From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole sitting in for Ira Glass. And our show today is about rules and when it might be OK to break them, when it's even right to break them. About a year ago, summer 2019, my friend Benjamen Walker was in Nairobi, in Kenya, working on this project with some folks from the London School of Economics. And about four days into his trip, he found himself downtown, idly walking past this big, huge recreation area called Uhuru Park.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。今天的节目是关于规则，以及什么时候破坏规则可能是可以接受的，甚至什么时候破坏规则是正确的。大约一年前，即2019年夏天，我的朋友本杰明·沃克在肯尼亚内罗毕，与伦敦政治经济学院的一些人合作开展一个项目。旅程进行到第四天时，他发现自己身处市中心，漫无目的地走过一个叫做乌胡鲁公园的巨大休闲区。
And boom. There was the protesters.
突然。抗议者就在那里。
How many of them were there?
有多少人？
Like 300.
大概300人。
There's, what, 300 people here?
那里有300人左右吗？
Just a mass of people-- like, men.
只是一大群人——全都是男性。
And the thing they were protesting was Uber. They were Uber drivers on strike. Like I said, 2019. You might remember there were a lot of Uber strikes all over the world around this time.
他们抗议的对象是优步（Uber）。他们是在罢工的优步司机。正如我所说，那是2019年。你可能记得那段时间全球各地都有许多针对优步的罢工。
Uber had been in Kenya for about four years, and these drivers had the same complaint that's followed the company wherever it's gone. Uber makes too much off the rides. They make too little. They want more of the pie. And they were mad.
优步进入肯尼亚已有四年左右，这些司机有着与该公司所到之处相同的抱怨。优步从车费中抽成太多。他们赚得太少。他们想要分到更多蛋糕。他们非常愤怒。
Benjamen waded into the crowd of strikers with a microphone because that's what he does. He hosts a podcast you might have heard of called Benjamen Walker's Theory of Everything. And this story was right up his alley. He's done lots of stories about the gig economy and its discontents. This one driver, Jafar, said one thing that would get them more money is rules, more rules.
本杰明带着麦克风走进了罢工人群，因为这就是他的工作。他主持一个你可能听说过的播客，叫《本杰明·沃克的万物理论》。这个故事非常适合他。他做过许多关于零工经济及其不满情绪的报道。其中一位名叫贾法尔的司机说，能让他们赚到更多钱的一件事就是规则，更多的规则。
It is just about regulations, number one, number two, regulations, number three, regulations. We need regulations from the government. Because when you are regulated, you cannot come over here, make money, vote in New York Stock Exchange, flow to your whatever-- IPO-- and investor billionaires come and take. Yeah?
这完全是关于监管，第一是监管，第二是监管，第三还是监管。我们需要政府的监管。因为当你受到监管时，你不能来到这里，赚钱，在纽约证券交易所投票，流向你的任何地方——首次公开募股（IPO）——然后让亿万富翁投资者拿走一切。对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And when we have regulations, we will never see a driver working 18 hours a day. Are we together?
当我们有了监管，我们就再也不会看到一个司机每天工作18个小时了。我们达成共识了吗？
How do you win? That's what I want to know. How do you win?
你们如何取胜？这就是我想知道的。你们如何取胜？
Solidarity.
团结。
That was another driver there. Solidarity means everyone participating in the work stoppage. Except from what Benjamen saw that week, there were plenty of other Uber drivers still out working. In fact, even as they were all standing there, 300 strong, protesting against Uber--
那是那里的另一位司机。团结意味着每个人都参与停工。但根据本杰明那周所看到的，还有很多其他优步司机仍在工作。事实上，就在他们300人站在一起抗议优步的时候——
We are now on strike, and there's another guy carrying passenger around--
我们现在罢工了，还有另一个家伙在载客——
No, no.
不，不。
You see, there is car here packed with passenger.
你看，这里有辆车里坐着乘客。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
So there is, like, a road that goes through this part of the park. And some guy, Uber driver, decided to go through the protest.
公园这部分有一条路穿过。有个家伙，一个优步司机，决定穿过抗议人群。
Through the protest?
穿过抗议人群？
Yeah.
是的。
And they know he's an Uber driver how? He has the little Uber sign in his window or something?
他们怎么知道他是优步司机？他的车窗上有个小优步标志还是什么的？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And they swarm his car. And then--
对，对，对。然后他们蜂拥围住他的车。接着——
[AIR HISSING]
[空气嘶嘶声]
--they let the air out of the tires.
——他们放掉了轮胎里的气。
[WHISTLING]
[哨声]
That's how I'm going to deal with them. Let the car stay down, eh?
这就是我处理他们的方式。让车停下，对吧？
That's how we deal with traitors.
这就是我们对待叛徒的方式。
And what did the guy do?
那个人做了什么？
He seemed pretty upset. He kind of sat there in shock for a while.
他看起来很心烦。他坐在那里震惊了好一会儿。
He stayed in his car.
他留在车里了。
He got out. Eventually, even some of the protesters helped him move it out of the way.
他下车了。最终，甚至一些抗议者还帮他把车挪开了。
Of course. He's still our brother, anyway. Good or bad, he's still our brother. We fight them, and we help them at the same time.
当然。无论如何，他还是我们的兄弟。无论好坏，他依然是我们的兄弟。我们与他们抗争，同时也帮助他们。
Yes.
是的。
This was one of two Uber drivers that tried to drive through the middle of the protest while Benjamen was there. And one of the protesters said, oh, the reason they're still driving is that with all of us on strike, the surge pricing kicked in. So the ones who keep at it make more money, which is to say it's hard to beat Uber at this game. House always wins.
本杰明在场时，有两名优步司机试图穿过抗议人群。其中一名抗议者说，噢，他们还在开车的理由是，我们所有人都罢工时，动态定价生效了。所以那些坚持开车的人赚得更多，也就是说，在这个游戏中很难打败优步。庄家永远是赢家。
But then as they all stood around discussing this, one of the drivers told Benjamen about a kind of a workaround they had up their sleeve-- a cheat code.
但当他们聚在一起讨论这件事时，其中一位司机告诉本杰明他们袖子里藏着的一种变通方法——一种作弊码。
So, all right, now I have a question for you. So the last two days, I took some Ubers, I told you, when I was here.
好吧，现在我有个问题问你。我在这里的这两天，我打了几次优步，我告诉过你。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
So I'm here till Thursday. I'm not going to take another Uber. What do I do, just find a taxi driver at the hotel?
我待到周四。我不打算再打优步了。我该怎么办，直接在酒店找个出租车司机吗？
And he's like, oh, you can just go karura.
他说，噢，你可以直接去卡鲁拉（karura）。
Karura is the way we normally call it. It's our language. Karura, you get a rider. You look at the estimate. You switch off the app. You go with the estimate, which means Uber will not get the commission.
卡鲁拉是我们通常的叫法。那是我们的语言。卡鲁拉，你找个乘客。你看一下预估价格。你关掉应用程序。你按预估价格交易，这意味着优步拿不到佣金。
So just to be clear, imagine you request a ride, and it automatically shows you how much it's going to cost. And when the driver shows up, you say to them, how about I hit cancel on the app and just give you the estimate in cash, cutting out the middleman?
为了清楚起见，想象一下你叫了一辆车，它自动显示了费用。当司机出现时，你对他说，我取消应用程序上的订单，直接给你现金，省去中间商怎么样？
That is what we call karura.
这就是我们所说的卡鲁拉。
So if I was to say to a driver, I want to go karura, is that how I would say it?
如果我对司机说，我想去卡鲁拉，是这样说吗？
Yes, yes, can you go karura? [LAUGHS] Yeah, you can tell the driver, can you go karura? He'll understand.
是的，是的，你能去卡鲁拉吗？[笑] 对，你可以告诉司机，你能去卡鲁拉吗？他会明白的。
[CAR DOOR OPENS]
[车门打开]
Mr. Benjamen.
本杰明先生。
Yes.
是的。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good. And you?
我很好。你呢？
Fine, fine.
很好，很好。
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. I want to-- all right, so this ride-- hey, where's my ride? My ride is 380, OK?
等等。等等，等等。我想——好吧，这趟车——嘿，我的车在哪儿？我的车是380，对吧？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
I want to give you 400, and we go karura. And I cancel.
我想给你400，我们去卡鲁拉。我取消订单。
OK.
好的。
All right, cool. So I canceled it. Yep.
好，太棒了。我已经取消了。是的。
So how did it feel once you did that?
当你这样做之后，感觉如何？
It felt great. On the one hand, it solves all of my problems for the rest of this trip. But also, I almost feel like I've gotten the answer to my question, because I wanted to know how you win. And there's something about going karura, which is basically using the tools against the company. I mean, it's great.
感觉很棒。一方面，它解决了我在这次旅行剩余时间里的所有问题。但我也觉得我几乎得到了我问题的答案，因为我想知道如何获胜。而“去卡鲁拉”这件事有些东西，本质上就是利用这些工具来对付公司。我的意思是，这很棒。
And it's subversive. One of the protesters referred to it as economic sabotage-- i.e., until we get more rules governing Uber, we're going to break some.
而且这具有颠覆性。其中一名抗议者称其为经济破坏——即在我们获得更多监管优步的规则之前，我们要打破一些现有的。
I asked Uber if I could talk to a company rep in Kenya about going karura. A spokesperson for all of sub-Saharan Africa wrote back, saying, in part, "Repeat canceling by either a driver or rider could be flagged by our fraud technology, which will then result in an investigation." She also said it's not safe to go off app for the passengers or the drivers-- which, for the record, some of the drivers will tell you too that they don't like to do it, because having a record of the trip is safer for them.
我问优步我是否可以和肯尼亚的公司代表谈谈关于“去卡鲁拉”的事情。一位负责整个撒哈拉以南非洲的发言人回信说，部分内容是：“司机或乘客的重复取消订单可能会被我们的欺诈技术标记，这将导致调查。”她还说，对于乘客或司机来说，脱离应用程序是不安全的——顺便说一句，有些司机也会告诉你他们不喜欢这样做，因为有行程记录对他们来说更安全。
Of course, going under the radar like this isn't really anything that novel. Cab drivers in New York will sometimes say, hey, how about I turn off the meter and you pay me in cash? But they don't have a name for it. Benjamen and I both wondered, you know, why karura? It's the name of a forest in Nairobi, Karura Forest, but none of the drivers Benjamen rode with could really explain it beyond that.
当然，这种暗中操作并不是什么新奇事。纽约的出租车司机有时也会说，嘿，我关掉计价器，你付现金怎么样？但他们没有给它起个名字。我和本杰明都在想，为什么叫卡鲁拉？这是内罗毕的一个森林名称，卡鲁拉森林，但本杰明搭乘过的司机除了这个名字外都无法解释原因。
OK, I don't know who came up with that name.
好吧，我不知道是谁想出这个名字的。
And when I started calling around to drivers and transport officials in Nairobi, this funny thing happened.
当我开始打电话给内罗毕的司机和交通官员时，发生了件有趣的事。
Karura, yeah. [LAUGHS] That's what we call it.
卡鲁拉，是的。[笑] 这就是我们叫它的方式。
All of them giggled when I said it. Like, oh, that. You want to know about that? How do you know about that? And one of the drivers said, oh, you can go karura.
当我提到这个词时，他们都咯咯地笑。就像，噢，那个啊。你想了解那个？你是怎么知道的？其中一位司机说，噢，你可以去卡鲁拉。
Yeah, it's called-- [LAUGHS]
是的，它叫——[笑]
Yeah, karura. I know karura. [LAUGHS]
是的，卡鲁拉。我知道卡鲁拉。[笑]
Yeah. [LAUGHS] Karura.
是的。[笑] 卡鲁拉。
One of them told me before Uber came to town, those informal taxis that you haggle with, a lot of them stationed themselves around Karura Forest. So now it was a kind of catch-all phrase for paying any sort of driver under the table. That's the most rational explanation. But there was this other explanation that came from a driver who I'm calling Roger.
其中一人告诉我，优步来到这个城市之前，许多你讨价还价的那些非正式出租车都驻扎在卡鲁拉森林周围。所以现在它成了一个为付给任何司机私下费用的万能词。这是最合理的解释。但还有另一种解释，来自我称之为罗杰的司机。
Karura, yes. I think I have a clue.
卡鲁拉，是的。我想我有条线索。
He's 30 years old, has a one-year-old son, been driving since Uber first came to Kenya. He's also a graphic designer, has a degree in business and IT. He's worked in the hotel industry. He's done a lot of things.
他30岁，有一个一岁的儿子，从优步刚进入肯尼亚就开始开车了。他也是一名平面设计师，拥有商业和信息技术学位。他在酒店行业工作过。他做过很多事情。
Karura is a forest.
卡鲁拉是一片森林。
Yeah.
是的。
So we're assuming these are laws that we just got from the forest. So it's quote, unquote, "jungle law." Let me call it jungle law.
所以我们假设这些是从森林里得到的法律。所以它是所谓的“丛林法则”。让我称它为丛林法则。
You're saying jungle law?
你是说丛林法则？
Yes, jungle law. So it's something not allowed, and again, it's something not in the constitution of Uber.
是的，丛林法则。所以它是某种不允许的事情，而且再次强调，它是优步宪法中没有的东西。
Something not in the laws of Uber.
优步法律中没有的东西。
Yes, a jungle law we formed ourself.
是的，我们自己形成的丛林法则。
I see. So if Uber are the authorities, then karura is sort of skirting the authorities.
我明白了。所以如果优步是权威，那么卡鲁拉就是某种绕过权威的做法。
Yes, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
Got you.
明白了。
Yeah.
是的。
How does that feel when you're going karura versus using the app?
当你“去卡鲁拉”和使用应用程序相比，感觉如何？
You see, it's a nice feeling. Let me say that, because you're having an extra coin.
你看，那是一种很好的感觉。让我这么说吧，因为你多赚了一枚硬币。
Extra coin.
额外的硬币。
And you just feel like you've worked for it, and you don't-- and nobody else deserve to get a share of it. I can say you feel empowered in terms of you feel like you're open-minded entrepreneur.
你只是觉得这是你努力得来的，而且你不需要——没有人应该分享它。我可以说是你感到有权势，因为你觉得自己是一个思想开放的企业家。
Entrepreneur, yeah.
企业家，是的。
Reason being, the company wants this, and the client wants this. So what do you do? You have to open up your mind and either to take the decision to make an extra coin or probably to listen to the company and go home empty-handed.
原因是，公司想要这个，客户也想要这个。那你怎么做？你必须放开你的思维，要么决定去赚那枚额外的硬币，要么听公司的话然后空手回家。
Right, it's up to you at that point. You have to make--
没错，那时候全看你自己了。你必须做出——
Yes, it's up to you.
是的，全看你自己。
--an independent decision.
——一个独立的决定。
Yes.
是的。
But it is breaking a rule.
但这是在打破规则。
Yes, yes, yes, it is.
是的，是的，是的，确实是。
I mean, I guess I wonder if that factors into the decision making of like, well, I know it's a rule. Should I break this rule? Like, we're supposed to follow rules and everything.
我是说，我猜我在想这是否会影响决策，比如，嗯，我知道这是一个规则。我应该打破这个规则吗？比如，我们应该遵循规则之类的。
Because, you see, at the end of the day, the reason why you get up and decide to get into business is, at the end of the day, you get home with something, you see? So if you decide your priority is following rules, most of the days you're going to get home empty-handed. And most of us are young families. You see, we have wives. We have kids in the house. So if you decide that you're going to be strict to the letter, that you're going to follow all the rules, believe you me, your family is going to sleep hungry.
因为，你看，归根结底，你起床决定做生意的原因是，归根结底，你得带点东西回家，你明白吗？所以如果你决定你的首要任务是遵守规则，大多数时候你都会空手而归。而我们大多数人都是年轻家庭。你看，我们有妻子。家里有孩子。所以如果你决定要严格执行，要遵循所有规则，相信我，你的家人会饿着肚子睡觉。
It's not just empowering to break the rules sometimes. Sometimes it's necessary to break the rules-- or anyway, it feels like it is. And today on our show, we have stories of people defying regulations, violating the social contract to make a point, and in one case, to strike out against the inequities of a sixth grade class. Please stay with us.
有时打破规则不仅仅是赋予权力。有时打破规则是必要的——无论如何，感觉就是这样。今天我们的节目里，有关于人们蔑视法规、违反社会契约以表达观点，在一种情况下，是为了反抗六年级班级中的不平等现象的故事。请留在我们身边。
Act One, Time Bandit. There was a moment this year when I watched someone break the rules right in front of me in the most dramatic way. Dramatic is the operative word because it was during a performance. It wasn't just in front of me. There were hundreds of people in the audience.
第一幕，时间强盗。今年有一个时刻，我看着有人在表演中以最戏剧性的方式打破了规则。之所以说戏剧性，是因为它发生在表演期间。它不仅仅发生在我面前。观众席里有数百人。
This was during an event that I go to every year, if I can make it, on New Year's Day. It's a 10-hour-long marathon of performances-- I call it a marathon-- at the St. Mark's Poetry Project in a 200-year-old church in Lower Manhattan. So imagine a soaring, cavernous sanctuary with a podium on the altar up front.
这是我每年元旦尽可能参加的活动。这是一个为期10小时的表演马拉松——我称之为马拉松——在曼哈顿下城的圣马可诗歌项目，位于一座200年历史的教堂里。所以想象一个高耸、空旷的圣殿，前面祭坛上有一个讲台。
Mostly, the marathon is set up as a kind of churn. There are more than 150 people on the program. And it's not just poetry readings, but bands play, and there are choreographers and comedians. I've seen Patti Smith perform there and Philip Glass.
大多时候，马拉松被设定为一种流水线。节目单上有超过150人。这不仅是诗歌朗诵，还有乐队表演，以及编舞家和喜剧演员。我见过帕蒂·史密斯和菲利普·格拉斯在那里表演。
And everybody only gets two to three minutes each to read, or play, or whatever. The time limit's a big deal, because they need to fit everybody in. Occasionally, someone gets on stage in between acts and tells everybody to keep it short. Anyway, the sort of rule-shattering moment that happened was not one of the famouses onstage. It was somebody I'd never heard of.
每个人只有两到三分钟的时间来朗诵、演奏或做任何事。时间限制是一个大问题，因为他们需要容纳每个人。偶尔，有人会在节目间隙上台告诉大家要简短点。不管怎样，那种打破规则的时刻并不是舞台上的名人。而是一个我从未听说过的人。
Jerome Ellis is a composer, performer, and writer. His recent work--
杰罗姆·埃利斯是一位作曲家、表演者和作家。他最近的作品——
Jerome Ellis, composer and musician, but he didn't have an instrument with him or even anything to read off of. He just climbed up on stage, stood in front of the mic. And I have to admit, I was really just looking down at my program and not paying attention when he started talking.
杰罗姆·埃利斯，作曲家和音乐家，但他没有带乐器，甚至没有任何东西可以照着读。他只是走上舞台，站在麦克风前。我必须承认，当他开始说话时，我真的只是低头看着节目单，没有注意。
The Brazilian state of Mato Grosso do Sul has a law mandating that cell phone companies offer a 50%--
巴西马托格罗索州有一项法律，要求手机公司提供50%的——
And then he stopped talking, like for a while. And I think it was at this point that I looked up and saw him sort of staring, wide eyed, maybe trembling a bit. I'm playing this in real time, by the way. Normally, I'd edit these silences down, but I wanted to give you a sense of how confusing this was at first, and uncomfortable.
然后他停止了说话，就像停顿了一会儿。我想就是在那一刻，我抬起头，看到他眼神茫然，或许还有点颤抖。顺便说一下，我是在实时播放这个片段。通常我会剪掉这些沉默，但我希望能让你感觉到这起初是多么令人困惑和不安。
50%--
50%——
I had no idea what was going on. So far he had said, "The Brazilian state of Mato Grosso do Sul has a law mandating that cell phone companies offer a 50%--"
我完全不知道发生了什么。到目前为止，他说的是：“巴西马托格罗索州有一项法律，要求手机公司提供50%的——”
--discount to--
——折扣给——
And then you can hear he's doing these kind of little, breathy clicks and pops.
然后你可以听到他发出那种轻微的、带呼吸声的咔哒声和爆破声。
[SOFT POPPING SOUNDS]
[轻微的爆破声]
And I was like, oh, it's some performance art thing, like cell phone companies' spotty coverage in Brazil.
当时我想，噢，这是一种行为艺术，比如手机公司在巴西信号覆盖不稳定。
To their customers--
给他们的客户——
"With 50% discount to their customers."
“给他们的客户提供50%的折扣。”
With--
给——
And then he breaks into Portuguese.
然后他转成了葡萄牙语。
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[说葡萄牙语]
--customers with breaks in the timing and fluency of speech. That is, the customers who have speech impediments, like myself.
——客户，语言表达有停顿和不连贯。也就是说，那些患有语言障碍的客户，像我一样。
So that's what was going on.
原来这就是怎么回事。
They have to-- the customer has to present--
他们必须——客户必须出示——
Jerome has a stutter.
杰罗姆有口吃。
--a signed statement from a speech language--
——一份来自语言治疗师的签名证明——
A significant one.
一种严重的口吃。
Speech language-- speech language pathologist to prove their pathology. I first encountered this law in a book about strange laws from around the world. The author of the book was mocking the law. But I see in the law an attempt to address the issue of temporal accessibility--
语言治疗师——语言病理学家，来证明他们的病理。我第一次遇到这条法律是在一本关于世界各地奇怪法律的书里。那本书的作者在嘲笑这项法律。但我看到了法律试图解决时间可及性问题——
Temporal accessibility.
时间可及性。
--when it comes to-- when it comes-- when it comes-- when it comes to disabled speech. So when I was first invited to participate in this magnificent event, I was struck by the two-minute time limit, which later became a two- to three-minute time limit. And I understood intuitively that the purpose of this time limit was to create as non-hierarchical a space as possible.
——当涉及到——当涉及到——当涉及到——当涉及到残疾人语言时。所以当我第一次被邀请参加这个宏大的活动时，我被两分钟的时间限制所震撼，后来变成了两到三分钟。我直观地理解，这个时间限制的目的是尽可能创建一个非等级化的空间。
But in removing one hierarchy, the time limit introduces another. A time limit assumes that all people have relatively equal access to time through their speech, which is not true. Stuttering is very unpredictable. I can rehearse something as many times as I want, but I don't actually know how long it will take to say anything until I have to say it.
但在消除一个等级制度时，时间限制引入了另一个。时间限制假设所有人通过语言获得时间的机会相对均等，但这并不真实。口吃是非常不可预测的。我可以根据需要排练多少次，但在我不得不说出来之前，我真的不知道说任何话需要多长时间。
What you just heard is about half of Jerome's performance as he performed it that night, my commentary not withstanding. It clocks in at about five minutes, practically twice the length permitted itself. I'll play you the second half in a bit. But in just those five minutes, I'd gone from barely paying attention to being totally rapt. Everybody was.
你刚才听到的是杰罗姆那天晚上表演的一半，不管我的评论如何。总时长大约五分钟，几乎是允许时长的两倍。我稍后会为你播放下半部分。但仅仅在那五分钟里，我已经从几乎不关注变得完全沉浸其中。每个人都一样。
The pauses continued, some of them longer than what you just heard. And in an enormous room packed with people, there was barely any other sound. I don't remember hearing a cough or a paper rustle. We were all just kind of spellbound-- partly, I think, because as Jerome said himself, what was happening on stage seemed so very unpredictable. That's what it felt like in the audience.
停顿继续着，有些比你刚才听到的还要长。在一个挤满人的巨大房间里，几乎听不到其他声音。我不记得听到过咳嗽声或纸张摩擦声。我们都有点被迷住了——部分原因，我认为，正如杰罗姆自己所说，舞台上发生的事情看起来太不可预测了。这就是观众的感受。
And in the weeks and months since then, I realized I just had all these questions for Jerome, the way you wish you could call up the person who made the weird, obscure movie you just saw that you can't get out of your head or who wrote the book you just read. I just wanted to know how he thought of what he did, how it felt to do that.
从那以后的几周和几个月里，我意识到我有很多问题想问杰罗姆，就像你希望给那个你刚才看过的、难以忘怀的奇怪电影的导演打电话，或者给那个你刚读完的书的作者打电话一样。我只是想知道他是怎么想到他所做的事的，做这件事是什么感觉。
Jerome.
杰罗姆。
Sean, hi.
肖恩，嗨。
Hey. How are you?
嘿。你好吗？
I'm doing well.
我很好。
So I called him on Skype. He's got the friendliest face and hadn't had a haircut in a while, like everybody. Jerome told me he got the idea after the director of The Poetry Project sent him an email inviting him to perform and mentioned the time limit. And just reading that gave him this twinge of stress.
所以我用Skype给他打了电话。他有一张最友好的脸，很久没理发了，像大家一样。杰罗姆告诉我，在诗歌项目的导演发邮件邀请他表演并提到时间限制后，他有了这个想法。仅仅读到那个就让他感到一阵压力。
And I was like-- I was like-- I noted the stress. And I was like, oh, I think I'm interested in going towards that stress and exploring that.
然后我就像——我注意到那种压力。我想，噢，我想走向那种压力并探索它。
He says, that confusion I felt at first, that's what he was going for. Because it's so common for people to have that feeling upon meeting him. They don't know what's going on until he tells them. It's not easy to bring hundreds of people simultaneously into an experience you live everyday, but he managed it. I also wondered if he had kind of improvised what he was going to say, but he says he wrote it all out ahead of time and rehearsed it, reading it off his phone while walking down the street, which was way easier than reciting it onstage, he says.
他说，我起初感受到的那种困惑，正是他想要的。因为人们第一次见到他时有这种感觉是很常见的。直到他告诉他们，他们才明白发生了什么。让数百人同时进入你每天生活的体验并不容易，但他做到了。我也想知道他是否即兴发挥了他的演讲，但他说是他提前写好并排练过的，一边走在街上一边看手机读，他说这比在舞台上背诵容易得多。
What was the shortest amount of time that it took when you were preparing, when you were rehearsing it?
在你准备、排练时，最短用了多少时间？
I would say-- I would say two and 1/2 minutes.
我想说——我想说是两分半钟。
Two and 1/2 minutes, got it.
两分半钟，明白了。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was important to him, he says, to write something that someone who didn't stutter could recite within the time limit. So in that way he was simultaneously adhering to the rules and breaking them at the same time. And since stuttering is unpredictable, Jerome says there was a chance the whole thing could have taken him only four minutes. Then it was a funny situation, where stuttering less might have made it harder for people to understand the point he was trying to make. I figured simply being on stage would make him more likely to stutter, but Jerome says no.
他说这对他很重要，写出一些不口吃的人能在时间限制内背诵的东西。所以从某种意义上说，他同时在遵守规则和打破规则。既然口吃是不可预测的，杰罗姆说整个过程他可能只需要四分钟。那么情况就会变得很滑稽，口吃得少反而可能使人们更难理解他想表达的观点。我以为仅仅站在舞台上就会让他更有可能口吃，但杰罗姆说不。
It's, in fact, quite soothing to be on stage because it's like-- you know, it's like I actually feel that I'm-- that I have the time. And in some ways, the stage-- the stage-audience relationship is a more temporally accessible environment than other environments of verbal-- verbal-- verbal-- verbal communication that I engage with.
事实上，站在舞台上感觉相当令人宽慰，因为它就像——你知道，就像我真的感觉到——我有时间。从某些方面来说，舞台与观众的关系是一个比我参与的其他言语——言语——言语——言语交流环境更具时间可及性的环境。
Like when he worked at the Columbia Law Library, just to give you some background of his life offstage. Jerome worked at the circulation desk. And not only did he have to take in calls, but he had to transfer calls to other people. So answering the phone, that's one temporal expectation. And then having to explain to someone else who's calling while the first person's on hold, now he's squashed between two temporal expectations. It was stressful.
比如他在哥伦比亚大学法学院图书馆工作时，简单介绍一下他舞台下的生活。杰罗姆在借书处工作。他不仅要接电话，还要把电话转给别人。所以接听电话，那是某种时间预期。然后当第一个人在通话等待时，不得不向另一个打电话的人解释，现在他被夹在两种时间预期之间了。那压力很大。
Also, this show and radio in general is not usually an accessible environment for differently-abled speakers. I'm leaving in a lot of Jerome's stutters in the interview part of this story, but I'm still cutting out some of his pauses and repeats-- and mine, for that matter. As a group of professionals, we're biased toward more fluid talkers. I became acutely aware of that while editing our conversation. And just to let you know, I tried to quote, unquote, "clean up" his answers as little as possible because I want to bring you into Jerome's daily experience too.
此外，这个节目和整个广播通常也不是一个对残疾说话者友好的环境。我在故事的采访部分保留了杰罗姆的许多口吃，但我仍然剪掉了一些他的停顿和重复——当然也剪掉了我的。作为一个专业群体，我们偏向于更流利的说话者。在编辑我们的谈话时，我敏锐地意识到了这一点。只是想让你知道，我尽量不去润色他的回答，因为我也想把你带入杰罗姆的日常体验中。
Anyway, I think Jerome stuttered less than usual on the call with me because I know he stutters. He says it helps to disclose it, relaxes him. And then there are other subtler ways that he's able to tame it sometimes when he's talking to people.
不管怎样，我觉得杰罗姆在和我通话时口吃得比平时少，因为我知道他口吃。他说披露这一点有帮助，会让他放松。还有其他更微妙的方式，有时他在和人说话时能控制它。
Sometimes I refer to it as "my stutter," but sometimes I refer to it as "the stutter."
有时我称之为“我的口吃”，但有时我称之为“这个口吃”。
The stutter.
这个口吃。
Because to me, stuttering is not bound to my body, that it is a phenomenon that occurs between me and whoever I'm speaking to. I like to think of it like it's something that we share.
因为对我来说，口吃并不是束缚在我的身体里，它是一种发生在我与任何和我说话的人之间的现象。我喜欢认为这就像是我们共同拥有的某种东西。
And when Jerome's in a conversation with someone, he stutters partly because the burden to talk smoothly is only on him.
当杰罗姆与人交谈时，他口吃部分是因为只有他一人承担流利说话的负担。
Exactly, exactly. One way of saying that's like, oh, he's stuttering. But there's another way that's like, there is a stutter happening, you know.
正是如此。有一种说法是，噢，他在口吃。但还有另一种说法是，有一个口吃正在发生，你知道吗。
And we are both contending with it.
而且我们都在处理它。
Exactly.
正是。
And his talk at The Poetry Project was that on a grand scale. That's what he wanted-- for each of us to shoulder a little of the weight of the stutter that was happening.
而他在诗歌项目的演讲就是那件事的宏大缩影。那就是他想要的——让我们每个人承担一点正在发生的口吃的重量。
The reason for those long silences on stage is something that I didn't know either. Jerome's particular kind of stutter is sometimes called a glottal block. The way he explains it, when your vocal chords are at rest, they're apart. And then when you go to talk, they come together and vibrate. But sometimes, Jerome's vocal chords get stuck in the middle between being at rest and touching. So he can still make little sounds with his teeth and tongue and lips, but not his voice.
舞台上那些长久沉默的原因也是我以前不知道的。杰罗姆的那种口吃有时被称为声门阻塞。按他的解释，当你的声带处于休息状态时，它们是分开的。然后当你去说话时，它们聚在一起并振动。但有时，杰罗姆的声带被卡在休息和接触之间。所以他仍然可以用牙齿、舌头和嘴唇发出小声音，但不能用他的声音。
And talking to him on Skype, the same thing would happen as when he was on stage. When the glottal block came, he got this look-- a kind of frozen, wide-eyed stare like he was stunned. Except on stage, it was more dramatic. His face would turn upward. And I remember thinking to myself, is that just effort? Is it fear?
在Skype上和他交谈时，同样的事情也发生了。当声门阻塞出现时，他露出了那种表情——一种冻结的、眼神茫然的注视，仿佛他惊呆了。只是在舞台上，它更具戏剧性。他的脸会向上转。我记得对自己想，那是单纯的努力吗？是恐惧吗？
Yeah. And I know the look you're-- you're speaking about. Yeah, it's like some stutterers will-- their body will-- will, in fact, move a lot while they're stuttering. Their face will-- will move in certain ways, which I do sometimes. But in general, my body response is actually-- is a freezing. And-- and I stop breathing often too. Just like-- like it feels like everything stops for a second or five seconds or longer.
是的。我知道你说的那个表情。是的，就像有些口吃者——他们的身体会——在口吃时确实会移动很多。他们的脸会以某种方式移动，我有时也会这样。但总的来说，我的身体反应实际上——是冻结。而且——我也经常停止呼吸。就像——就像感觉一切都停止了一秒或五秒甚至更久。
So part of it is that-- is that I'm freezing. Part of it feels like my body goes into a kind of supplication or prayer almost. I have a friend who once referred to it as watching-- watching me ask for the word and wait, you know.
所以部分原因是——我是冻结了。部分感觉像我的身体进入了一种几乎是祈求或祈祷的状态。我有个朋友曾经称其为看着——看着我索要这个词并等待，你知道。
And wait for it to come?
并等待它的到来？
Wait for it to come, yeah. Yeah, because I often look up. It's a very specific state. It's like this-- there are some ways in which I, like, totally leave the room. And I think that speaks to the looking upward. And I then just, like-- I'll, like-- I'll come back once the word arrives.
等待它到来，是的。是的，因为我经常抬头。这是一种非常特殊的状态。这就像这种——在某些方面我，就像，完全离开了这个房间。我认为这解释了抬头看的行为。然后我就，就像——我会，就像——一旦这个词出现，我就会回来。
And it wasn't fear, he says. He does have a lot of fears in his daily life-- taking too much of someone's time, not being able to order at Shake Shack when there's a line behind him. But this wasn't that. If he was afraid of anything, it was falling back on the tactics he usually uses to get around a stutter-- synonyms, for example, swapping out a word he's blocked on for one that's easier to say. He didn't want to do that on stage.
他说那不是恐惧。他在日常生活中有很多恐惧——占用别人太多时间，当身后排着长队时在Shake Shack点餐点不出来。但这次不是那样。如果他害怕什么，那就是重新依赖他通常用来绕过口吃的策略——例如同义词，换掉一个他卡住的词，用一个更容易说的词代替。他不想在舞台上那样做。
And I didn't realize that until now, that I think that was the primary fear. And I did do that like two or three times, and I regretted it afterwards.
直到现在我才意识到，我认为那才是主要的恐惧。我确实那样做了两三次，事后我很后悔。
Do you remember which words you did it on, by any chance?
你还记得你是在哪些词上这样做的吗？
Yes.
记得。
To their customers with--
给他们的客户带有——
So there's the Portuguese word--
所以有那个葡萄牙语单词——
With.
带有。
"Disturbio."
“Disturbio。”
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[说葡萄牙语]
--which I had literally translated to-- in my text, I translated it-- translated it-- translated it-- translated it-- translated it-- translated it to just-- to disturbance. And as you just saw, that word still is like very hard for me to say. So what I did in the performance was--
——我把它字面翻译成了——在我的文本里，我翻译了——翻译了——翻译了——翻译了——翻译了——翻译了——翻译成了只是——紊乱（disturbance）。正如你刚才看到的，那个词对我来说仍然很难说。所以我表演时所做的是——
Customers with--
客户带有——
I said breaks.
我说的是间断（breaks）。
--breaks--
——间断——
Breaks in the timing and fluency of speech.
时间上的间断和语言的不连贯。
--in the timing and fluency of speech.
——在时间上的间断和语言的不连贯。
And that was one that I didn't like that I did that. What I wanted to do was what I-- I just did with-- with you, is just wait.
我不喜欢我那样做了。我想做的是我刚才对你做的，就是等待。
Wait for the word.
等待这个词。
Wait for it. But it was especially-- especially D's, they can be really painful.
等待它。但特别是——特别是D开头的词，它们真的会很痛苦。
Wow.
哇。
So that's why I avoided that one. And I was frustrated with myself. As soon as it happened-- like breaks to me, it doesn't capture what I wanted to capture.
所以这就是为什么我避免用那个词。我对自己感到沮丧。事情一发生——就像对我来说“间断”，它没有捕捉到我想要捕捉的东西。
Are names particularly difficult?
名字特别难吗？
Yes. Yeah, yeah. Because there's no synonyms for them, you know.
是的。是的，因为它们没有同义词，你知道。
Jerome blocks on his own name. Has since he was four years old, when his stutter started. So now trying to say his name or any name, he says it's like he's four again.
杰罗姆在自己的名字上卡壳。自四岁口吃开始以来一直如此。所以现在试图说他的名字或任何名字，他说就像他又回到了四岁。
I even-- I even, in some situations-- for a few years, I would say "John." John is my middle name. But very interestingly, I then began stuttering on John. And then I-- and then I would start saying Sean, because sometimes the "sh" sound is easy. Like, the "juh" sound has a harder attack.
我甚至——在某些情况下——有几年，我会说“约翰”。约翰是我的中间名。但非常有趣的是，我后来开始在约翰上口吃。然后我——然后我会开始说肖恩，因为有时“sh”声很容易。就像，“juh”声有一个更难的攻击。
And also, you know, obviously Sean is just an incredibly beautiful name.
而且，你知道，很明显，肖恩只是一个令人难以置信的美丽名字。
And that was really-- I mean, that was my-- that was my main reasoning for doing it. I was just like, well, if I'm going to-- if I'm going to choose a new name, why not just go straight for the top, you know what I mean?
那真的——我的意思是，那是我——那是我做这件事的主要理由。我只是想，嗯，如果我要——如果我要——选择一个新名字，为什么不直接选最好的，你明白我的意思吗？
Just go for the top, man.
直接选最好的，伙计。
So, you know. And then I started stuttering on that, you know. I mean, I just find that-- that so beautiful. It's like it's always outpacing me in a way.
所以，你知道。然后我开始在那上面口吃，你知道。我的意思是，我只是发现——那太美了。就像它总是以某种方式超过我。
You find that beautiful that it's outpacing you?
你发现它超过你是美丽的？
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I find it painful too, but I-- but I find a deep beauty in that.
是的。我的意思是，我也觉得它很痛苦，但我——但我从中发现了一种深沉的美。
What is the beauty?
美在哪里？
Well, for me it's this quality that it's like-- the stutter, it feels like this thing that is so deeply entwined with my body, my mind, my emotions, everything. And yet I can't figure it out, or I can't grasp it. And even more so, like when I think I have grasped it, like when I think I've outsmarted it even, like, by switching my name, there's something about just how elusive it is.
嗯，对我来说，这种特质是——口吃，感觉就像这件与我的身体、我的思想、我的情感，一切都如此紧密交织在一起的东西。然而我无法弄清楚它，或者我无法掌握它。更甚者，当我以为我已经掌握它时，比如当我以为我已经胜过它时，例如通过切换名字，那种它是多么难以捉摸的东西总有一些美感。
The second half of Jerome's performance was just one sentence. It took him four minutes and nine seconds to get through, partly because it had a name at the beginning.
杰罗姆表演的下半部分只是一个句子。他花了四分零九秒才说完，部分原因是因为开头有一个名字。
The Black feminist--
黑人女性主义——
The sentence begins, "The Black feminist scholar Kimberlé Crenshaw once wrote," and then a quote. Climbing on top of Crenshaw's name alone took him about a minute 45 seconds. I haven't paused the recording of the performance, by the way. It's still running underneath this.
句子开始是，“黑人女性主义学者金伯莱·克伦肖曾经写道，”然后是一段引用。仅仅爬上克伦肖的名字就花了他大约1分45秒。顺便说一下，我没有暂停表演的录音。它仍然在这段文字下运行。
My chest was hurting so much. And while I was doing it, I was like, god, should I just, like, give up and leave, you know? And I was like, no. I mean, I've done that so many-- like, I mean, there's so many moments in life where I just like-- I just stop speaking because I just don't want to put in-- in the labor of finishing my thought or finishing my sentence. And I was like, no, I don't want to do that here. I wanted to show the audience the labor that's involved. And this is labor that I often or sometimes won't put in.
我的胸口很痛。当我在做这件事时，我就想，天哪，我是不是该，就像，放弃然后离开，你知道吗？然后我想，不。我的意思是，我有很多次——我的意思是，生命中有太多的时刻，我只是就像——我只是停止说话，因为我只是不想投入——投入努力去完成我的想法或完成我的句子。我想，不，我不想在这里这样做。我想向观众展示其中涉及的劳动。这是我经常或有时不会投入的劳动。
The Black feminist scholar--
黑人女性主义学者——
But it was around this moment that the feeling in the room started to change again. There was no more confusion, obviously, and any concern or tension was gone too.
但就在那一刻左右，房间里的感觉开始再次改变。显然不再有困惑了，任何担心或紧张也都消失了。
Black feminist scholar--
黑人女性主义学者——
By this point, the importance of what Jerome was saying had landed on us. And the marriage between the thing he was saying and the way he was saying it-- like a poem elongated. So it just took us a little longer to catch up.
到这一点，杰罗姆所说内容的意义已经落在了我们身上。而他所说的事情和他说话方式之间的结合——就像一首延长的诗。所以我们需要一点更长的时间来跟上。
Kimberlé Crenshaw once wrote--
金伯莱·克伦肖曾经写道——
I'm going to stop the recording for a second and just read you the quote so you can sit with it during this last part. It goes, "Treating different things the same can generate as much an inequality as treating the same things differently."
我要暂停一下录音，把引言读给你听，这样你可以在最后一部分思考它。它是这样说的：“把不同的事物等同对待，可能会产生与把相同事物区别对待一样多的不平等。”
Did you feel kind of punk rock to be doing that or, like, badass to be like--
你觉得那样做有点朋克摇滚，或者说，像个狠角色，比如——
Yeah. I mean, I felt like it was an act of resistance. And like-- and like, I'm-- as a musician, the first music I studied really deeply was jazz. And I remember very distinctly when I was in middle school that I would be-- I would have my jazz CDs at home. And often, they would be like four tracks, because each track would be like nine minutes long.
是的。我的意思是，我觉得这是一种抵抗行为。而且——作为一个音乐家，我研究最深的早期音乐是爵士乐。我非常清楚地记得，当我在中学时，我在家里有我的爵士CD。通常，它们会有四首曲目，因为每首曲目会有九分钟长。
And then I remember like looking at my friends' CDs of-- of punk rock, for example, as you mentioned, and like, you know, much shorter tracks. I remember-- I remember noticing that at that age and, like, thinking about what that meant. And there would be this refusal to adhere to the length of a pop song, for example, you know.
然后我记得像看我朋友们的CD——比如朋克摇滚，正如你提到的，像，你知道，短得多的曲目。我记得——我记得在那时注意到了这一点，并思考这意味着什么。人们会拒绝遵循流行歌曲的长度，例如，你知道。
And for me, there was always a racialized element there too, that there's, like, a Black resistance against certain structures of time, that like, no, this track is 11 minutes long. And if you don't want to listen to it, then don't listen to it. But like-- like, I'm like-- like, we're-- like, our-- what we're trying to achieve in this music is different in some ways than what a three-minute song is trying to achieve.
对我来说，那里总有一种种族化的元素，就像，有一种黑人对某些时间结构的抵抗，就像，不，这首曲子有11分钟长。如果你不想听，那就别听。但就像——就像，我们——就像，我们在这种音乐中试图实现的目标，在某些方面与一首三分钟的歌曲试图实现的目标不同。
Treating-- treating-- treating-- treating-- treating-- treating-- treating-- treating--
对待——对待——对待——对待——对待——对待——对待——对待——
As a Black person, I'm also thinking about the way that time and access to time is racially inflected. You know, there are many moments in the world when--
作为一个黑人，我也在思考时间和获得时间的方式是如何被种族影响的。你知道，世界上有很多时刻——
Treating--
对待——
--a person of color is just not given as much time to speak.
——有色人种只是没有得到那么多说话的时间。
Treating different things the same way may generate as much inequality as treating the same things in different ways. Thank you.
把不同的事物等同对待，可能会产生与把相同事物区别对待一样多的不平等。谢谢。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Jerome Ellis, Jerome Ellis.
杰罗姆·埃利斯，杰罗姆·埃利斯。
To learn more about Jerome Ellis and his many projects, visit jeromeellis.com. That's J-E-R-O-M-E E-L-L-I-S dot com. You can also follow him on Instagram. It's @ellisjerome.
要了解更多关于杰罗姆·埃利斯和他的许多项目，请访问jeromeellis.com。那是J-E-R-O-M-E E-L-L-I-S点com。你也可以在Instagram上关注他。是@ellisjerome。
Coming up, a story that perfectly encapsulates what my father always called the Golden Rule. Them that's got the gold makes the rules. That was his joke. That's in one minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来是一个完美概括我父亲常说的黄金法则的故事。拥有黄金的人制定规则。那是他的笑话。节目从芝加哥公共广播电台继续，一分钟后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, Made to Be Broken, stories about regulations, guidelines, proprieties that people upend for some just cause, as opposed to just 'cause. Act Two of our show today, It's All About the Jeffersons.
这是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。今天的节目，天生是为了被打破的，故事关于法规、准则、礼仪，人们为了某种正当理由而颠覆它们，而不是仅仅为了“为了某种理由”。我们今天的节目第二幕，全都是关于杰斐逊一家的。
When he was a kid, comedian Tone Bell was a rule follower. But there was one time he got into really big trouble, broke the rules in a serious way. And there's a Polaroid picture commemorating the moment. In his family, it became one of those iconic photographs, sort of family lore. They just called it the Polaroid. He explained the backstory to producer Elna Baker.
小时候，喜剧演员托恩·贝尔是一个遵守规则的人。但他有一次惹了大麻烦，以严重的方式打破了规则。有一张宝丽来照片纪念了那一刻。在他的家庭中，这成了标志性的照片之一，某种家族传说。他们干脆称之为“那张宝丽来”。他向制作人埃尔纳·贝克解释了背景故事。
When Tone started sixth grade at a new school, he got Ms. Dillard as his homeroom teacher. His neighbor, who we're calling MP, told him, that's not the teacher you want. You want Ms. Jefferson.
当托恩在新学校上六年级时，他被分到了迪拉德女士的班级。他的邻居，我们称之为MP，告诉他，那不是你想要的老师。你想要杰斐逊女士。
He definitely let me know that he had the better teacher, but I still didn't know why. I mean, I didn't know if it was because she was young and it was math, but I quickly learned why you wanted Ms. Jefferson.
他绝对让我知道他有更好的老师，但我还是不知道为什么。我的意思是，我不知道是因为她年轻，是教数学，但我很快就知道了为什么你想要杰斐逊女士。
Why do you want Ms. Jefferson?
为什么你想要杰斐逊女士？
Ms. Jefferson ran her own bank.
杰斐逊女士经营着她自己的银行。
Yeah, a bank. She was a math teacher, and she gave out fake money to the kids. When you did well on your homework or tests, you'd earn what she called Jefferson bucks, as in Ms. Jefferson, not Thomas. They came in denominations of one, five, and 10, and were actually printed.
是的，一家银行。她是数学老师，她给孩子们发假钱。当你作业或考试做得好时，你会得到她所称的“杰斐逊钱”，正如杰斐逊女士，而不是托马斯。它们有一、五和十的面值，而且是印出来的。
There was definitely a Jefferson mint. They were bills. They were straight up bills-- smaller than a real dollar, bigger than Monopoly money, but it kind of had that feel of Monopoly money. I mean, it looked like-- I mean, 12-year-old money. It looked like money. I'm 99% sure her face was on it.
绝对有一个杰斐逊铸币厂。它们是钞票。它们就是直截了当的钞票——比真正的美元小，比大富翁钱大，但确实有大富翁钱的那种感觉。我的意思是，它看起来像——我的意思是，12岁的钱。它看起来像钱。我有99%确定她的脸在上面。
Tone wasn't in Ms. Jefferson's homeroom like MP, who'd go to her homeroom four or five times a day. But he had her once a day for math, so he got to earn Jefferson bucks too. You could also make them for good behavior, like being quiet or helping her pass out papers.
托恩不在杰斐逊女士的班级，不像MP，他一天会去她的班级四五次。但他每天上数学课会见到她一次，所以他也能赚到杰斐逊钱。你也可以通过良好的行为赚取，比如安静或帮她发试卷。
I remember seeing one of my classmates open a door because one of the girls had stuff in her hand. That was like chivalrous, so he end up getting some money. I was like, oh, should you go open doors? I didn't know you could just be out here opening doors. Like, I don't know. I'm putting that on the list. Like, oh shit, I got to open some doors now. I mean, she had to notice it.
我记得看到我的一位同学开门，因为其中一个女孩手里拿着东西。那就像很有骑士精神，所以他最终得到了一些钱。我就想，噢，你应该去开门吗？我不知道你在这里随手开门就能赚钱。比如，我不知道。我把那个列在清单上了。比如，噢该死，我现在得去开几扇门了。我的意思是，她得注意到这一点。
So you're doing what?
所以你在做什么？
Oh, you're going above and beyond. I mean, you're knocking stuff off tables. You're knocking people's books off tables and then picking them up just so she can see a good deed. And then you're looking back at her like, you see what I did, right?
噢，你在超越自我。我的意思是，你在把东西从桌子上敲掉。你把人们的书从桌子上敲掉，然后捡起来，只是为了让她能看到一件善行。然后你看着她就像，你看到我做了什么吗，对吧？
At the end of the week, you could cash your Jefferson bucks in at the Jefferson Market, a little store Ms. Jefferson set up at her desk. Here, you could buy an extra 10 minutes at recess, as in everyone's coming inside and you're like, here's $5. I'm going to keep playing Red Rover by myself. Or you could buy school supplies, cheap plastic toys like little green army men, and candy, all sorts of candy. This was obviously the top seller. The kids even ranked it in order of preference.
周末，你可以在杰斐逊市场兑换你的杰斐逊钱，那是杰斐逊女士在她课桌上设置的小商店。在这里，你可以买到额外的10分钟课间休息，比如大家都进来了，你却说，这里有5块钱。我要自己继续玩红罗佛（Red Rover）。或者你可以买学习用品，便宜的塑料玩具，像小绿兵人，还有糖果，各种各样的糖果。这显然是畅销品。孩子们甚至按喜好程度给它们排了名。
So the Fun Dips and the Blow Pops and the Airheads were definitely, I want to say, like the top-tier candy-- maybe Skittles, like the long Jolly Ranchers. And you can tell. You could tell, especially with the Jefferson bucks-- like, if you only had $2, this is the drawer she opens because that's the cheap candy. Like, you don't have enough. Like, you got to pick from this bullshit candy.
所以Fun Dip糖果、Blow Pop棒棒糖和Airhead软糖绝对是，我想说，顶级糖果——也许还有彩虹糖，像长条的Jolly Rancher糖果。你可以看出来的。你可以看出来，尤其是用杰斐逊钱的时候——如果你只有2美元，这就是她打开的抽屉，因为那是便宜的糖果。比如，你钱不够。比如，你得从这些垃圾糖果里选。
Tone loved it. But then one day, a few weeks into the school year, this thing happened that changed how Tone thought about the Jefferson bucks system, and he couldn't get it out of his head. He was sitting with MP when he noticed something.
托恩很喜欢它。但后来有一天，学期过了几周，发生了一件事，改变了托恩对杰斐逊钱系统的看法，他无法从脑子里抹去。他和MP坐在一起时，他注意到了某件事。
I mean, I remember him having that plastic pencil case-- you know, pencils, protractor, ruler, all the stuff that you needed. He had so much money-- he had so much money, what that bag was used for turned into a wallet. I mean, it was just wads of Jefferson bucks.
我的意思是，我记得他有那个塑料笔盒——你知道，铅笔、量角器、尺子，所有你需要的东西。他钱太多了——他钱太多了，那个袋子最终变成了一个钱包。我的意思是，那全是一捆捆的杰斐逊钱。
I remember him taking that out. And it was almost like a secret because he didn't want everybody to-- and he threw me a couple dollars. And I saw-- I was like, how do you have that much money? It blew my mind. And then hearing like, oh, I made $11 today. I'm like, you made $11 today? Today?
我记得他把它拿出来。这几乎是个秘密，因为他不想让每个人都——然后他扔给我几美元。我看到——我就想，你怎么会有那么多钱？我惊呆了。然后听到他说，噢，我今天赚了11美元。我就想，你今天赚了11美元？今天？
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
It ain't even 2 o'clock yet. You got more time.
现在才不到2点呢。你还有更多时间。
Tone had been working his ass off for weeks, and all he had was six bucks, which was a tiny fraction of what MP had. Tone was earning a minimum wage, and MP was Jeff Bezos. He had to really sit with it before he understood how this could be. MP had Ms. Jefferson for homeroom and for math, which meant that he saw her four times throughout the day. Tone only saw her once for math. Of course, MP had way more Jefferson bucks.
托恩几周来一直在拼命工作，他只有六块钱，只是MP拥有的一小部分。托恩拿的是最低工资，而MP是杰夫·贝佐斯。他不得不认真思考了一会儿才明白这是怎么回事。MP在班级和数学课上都由杰斐逊女士教，这意味着他一天中四次见到她。托恩只在数学课上见她一次。当然，MP有更多的杰斐逊钱。
I remember seeing it and being envious, and being jealous, and wondering how I do that. And just like, let me switch my energy up. I'll study more. I'll be politer. I won't talk in class as much.
我记得看到它时的羡慕、嫉妒，以及想知道我该怎么做。我就想，让我改变一下能量吧。我会多学习。我会更礼貌。我上课不那么爱说话。
Tone tried all sorts of strategies to make money. But now that he saw the flaw in the system, he couldn't unsee it. Everything was a reminder of how much more opportunity the kids in her homeroom had.
托恩尝试了各种策略来赚钱。但现在他看到了系统中的漏洞，他无法视而不见。每件事都在提醒他，杰斐逊女士班上的孩子有多少机会。
It was almost like they had on fur coats and shit and driving Cadillacs. It almost felt like it made them dress better. It was like they were in the capital and we were District 12. We were just poor people trying to make it, and they are the elite.
这几乎就像他们穿着皮草大衣之类，开着凯迪拉克一样。它几乎让人觉得他们穿得更好。就像他们在国会，而我们是12区。我们只是穷人试图维持生计，而他们是精英。
And did that make you mad?
这让你生气吗？
Oh, it made me so fucking mad. It made me so mad because you don't know-- like, you know the rules and you know what's supposed to work, but then it doesn't work. But you see it worked for others.
噢，它让我他妈的非常生气。它让我非常生气，因为你不知道——比如，你知道规则，你知道什么应该有用，但它就是没用。但你看到它对别人有用。
To Tone, having money also meant something really important to him-- impressing girls. There was one girl in particular he had a huge crush on. We'll call her Natasha. She didn't even know Tone existed, but he thought about her all the time.
对托恩来说，有钱也意味着对他来说非常重要的一件事——给女孩留下深刻印象。有一个特别的女孩他非常迷恋。我们叫她娜塔莎。她甚至不知道托恩的存在，但他一直想着她。
Man, Natasha. Her name was on the back of my notebook and stuff. She was active and just long hair, brown skin-- just, like, beautiful. And her maturity level was up there. Her hair was always done. She always wore cool clothes.
天哪，娜塔莎。她的名字写在我的笔记本背面之类的。她很活跃，有着长发，棕色的皮肤——就是，很美。她的成熟程度也很高。她的头发总是做得很好。她总是穿很酷的衣服。
And she just had the attention. And you saw the dudes who were getting her attention. And look, man, to be honest with you, they just-- they had money. They had Jefferson bucks.
她只是吸引了注意力。你看到了那些得到她注意力的家伙。看，伙计，老实说，他们只是——他们有钱。他们有杰斐逊钱。
And would boys buy girls things with the Jefferson bucks?
男孩会用杰斐逊钱给女孩买东西吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah, we called that tricking off. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, definitely.
噢，会。是的。我们称之为“耍花招”。是的。我的意思是，绝对会。
Tone is 12, trying to figure out the whole girl thing for the first time and desperate to impress them. Luckily, there were other ways to make money besides Ms. Jefferson's class and way more ways to spend it. One of Tone's classmates explained to me that because Ms. Jefferson's store was only open on Friday, the kids came up with an underground economy of their own, a black market fueled by Jefferson bucks that was open every day of the week. You could buy anything there.
托恩12岁，第一次试图弄清楚关于女孩的一切，并迫切想要打动她们。幸运的是，除了杰斐逊女士的课堂，还有其他赚钱的方法，也有更多花钱的方法。托恩的一位同学向我解释说，因为杰斐逊女士的商店只在周五开放，孩子们想出了他们自己的地下经济，一个由杰斐逊钱驱动的黑市，每周每天都开放。你可以在那里买任何东西。
If somebody had jello, chocolate, or their dessert, we're like, hey, Maggie, three bucks for the half of your slice of pizza on Friday. I mean, somebody might sell you a pencil half price what Ms. Jefferson's going to sell it. Ms. Jefferson might have been selling the pencil, a graphic pencil, for $2, and you might be able to get it for $1. I mean, it became a legal tender basically through our sixth grade.
如果某人有果冻、巧克力或者他们的甜点，我们会说，嘿，玛吉，周五用你的一半披萨换三块钱。我的意思是，有人可能会卖给你半价的铅笔，那是杰斐逊女士要卖的价格。杰斐逊女士卖那支铅笔，一支美术铅笔，要2美元，你可能能花1美元买到。我的意思是，它基本上成了我们六年级通用的法定货币。
The kids did a lot of shady things, all under the table. Like kids in Ms. Jefferson's class would pay kids in Ms. Dillard's 10 to 20 Jefferson bucks to do their homework. That's how the black market worked if you had money. If you didn't--
孩子们做了许多阴暗的事情，都是私下进行的。比如杰斐逊女士班上的孩子会付给迪拉德女士班上的孩子10到20杰斐逊钱来做他们的作业。这就是黑市的工作方式，如果你有钱的话。如果你没有——
You've got to figure out how to leverage what they need so that you can get something that you're not getting, which is the Jefferson buck. I mean, there were moments where I remember, if you're not paying attention to your books, you might have a textbook stolen, and you're going to need five Jefferson bucks to get your book back.
你必须想办法利用他们需要的东西，这样你才能得到你得不到的东西，那就是杰斐逊钱。我的意思是，有那么一刻我记得，如果你不注意你的书，你可能会被偷走教科书，你需要五杰斐逊钱才能赎回你的书。
By December, the lopsidedness of Ms. Jefferson's system was clear to everyone in Ms. Dillard's homeroom. They complained to each other about it.
到了12月，杰斐逊女士系统的不均衡对迪拉德女士班上的每个人来说都很清楚。他们向彼此抱怨这一点。
And it's like, this shit is rigged. I don't remember who it was, but I remember a lot of us being like, yo, what do we need to do?
就像，这该死的系统是被操纵的。我不记得是谁说的，但我记得我们很多人就像，哟，我们需要做什么？
Did you ever say that to her?
你跟她说过吗？
Yeah, we brought it up, of how to-- like, how do we do more if you're not seeing it? I'm trying my best. And it's like nay, man. We got to have a town hall.
是的，我们提过，比如——如果她没看到，我们要怎么做更多？我正在尽我最大的努力。就像，不，伙计。我们得开个市政厅会议。
A kid brought it up one day in math class, and several others, including Tone, immediately jumped on board. I wasn't able to find Ms. Jefferson to get her side of this, but the way Tone remembers it, Ms. Jefferson shut this discussion down. If they wanted more money, she said, they needed to try harder, period, end of discussion.
有一天在数学课上一个孩子提了出来，其他人，包括托恩，立刻加入。我没能找到杰斐逊女士来听她的说法，但按照托恩的记忆，杰斐逊女士终止了这次讨论。她说，如果他们想要更多的钱，他们需要更努力地尝试，句号，讨论结束。
It's like, hey, man, everybody has the same opportunity. And it's like, no, they don't. Well, you got to work harder, and you got to try harder. And then after-- I'm saying months of doing that-- nothing, still nothing. And I just had this moment where I was like, I-- I've got to rob the Jefferson bank. Like, I'm going, there's no other way.
就像，嘿，伙计，每个人都有同样的机会。就像，不，他们没有。好吧，你得更努力工作，你得更努力尝试。然后之后——我说的是经过几个月的努力——什么都没有，还是什么都没有。我有那么一刻心想，我——我得去抢劫杰斐逊银行。就像，我要去了，没有别的办法。
Again, Tone was a rule follower. His dad was really strict. So this was wildly out of character. But as Bertolt Brecht said in a very different context, who's the greater criminal, the man who robs a bank or the man who founds one? Tone figured, if she can make-believe a bank, then he could rob that make-believe bank without any consequences.
再说一次，托恩是个遵守规则的人。他爸爸非常严厉。所以这极其不符合他的性格。但正如贝尔托·布莱希特在完全不同的语境中所说，谁是更大的罪犯，抢银行的人还是建立银行的人？托恩心想，如果她能假想一家银行，那么他就可以抢劫那家假想的银行而不用承担后果。
And then so I kind of just-- I mean, I guess I just kind of started casing Ms. Jefferson's actions. I knew we left a window open. At this point, we had her right before lunch. I knew where she kept it. I knew where the store was. I knew where the money was.
所以我猜我就只是——我猜我就只是开始观察杰斐逊女士的行为了。我知道她留了一扇窗户没关。此时，我们午饭前有她的课。我知道她把钱放在哪儿。我知道商店在哪儿。我知道钱在哪儿。
So at lunch-- so I decided a couple days before, I'm going to start going to the bathroom during lunch. I would go to the bathroom, come back. Spend, like, a little extra time, come back. You know, for a few days, just so this wouldn't look awkward either.
所以在午餐时——所以我决定提前几天，我开始在午餐时去洗手间。我会去洗手间，回来。花一点额外时间，回来。你知道，几天时间，只是为了让这看起来不那么突兀。
He's testing out how long he can be away without people noticing. Ms. Jefferson's classroom is locked during lunch, but she has a window that faces the courtyard. His plan is to slip in through the window, grab some money, and head out.
他正在测试在不引起注意的情况下他能离开多久。杰斐逊女士的教室在午餐时间是锁着的，但她有一个朝向庭院的窗户。他的计划是从窗户滑进去，拿点钱，然后离开。
So I was like, OK, today's the day. You know, I go the bathroom. And I asked the-- you know, excuse me, can I go to the bathroom real quick? I don't feel well.
我就想，OK，今天就是日子。你知道，我去洗手间。我问那个——你知道，不好意思，我能快速去下洗手间吗？我感觉不太好。
He goes straight to Ms. Jefferson's window in the courtyard, pushes it open, and climbs in. His heart is racing. And then he goes over to the one place every kid knows is forbidden, his teacher's desk. He knows exactly where Ms. Jefferson keeps the money, in the bottom right drawer. He opens the drawer and sees the metal cashbox. It's unlocked.
他径直走向庭院里杰斐逊女士的窗户，推开窗户，爬了进去。他的心在狂跳。然后他走向每个孩子都知道是禁地的那个地方，老师的桌子。他确切地知道杰斐逊女士把钱放在哪里，在右下角的抽屉里。他打开抽屉，看到了金属现金盒。它是没上锁的。
And so I open the box up. And, you know, I mean, just money. Even in that moment, I was like, oh-- this was like a Scrooge McDuck moment. Like, I am swimming in Jefferson bucks, but you can't get overzealous. Because if you take everything, that's definitely going to be noticeable. So you have to take enough to feel comfortable, but not enough to set off any alarms.
所以我把盒子打开了。我的意思是，全是钱。即使在那个时刻，我就想，噢——这就像那种史高治·麦克老鸭的时刻。就像，我正沉浸在杰斐逊钱里，但你不能表现得太贪婪。因为如果你拿走一切，那绝对会被发现。所以你得拿走足够让你感到舒服的钱，但又不能多到拉响警报。
And drawer opened up, popped the box, and grabbed out a nice-- I mean-- I mean, I'm going to say an inch thick of Jefferson bucks. I'm going to say, like, an inch, like a nice-- probably equivalent to what MP had in his pencil holder. And so I split that in half, and then I stuffed my pockets. And I'm like, I got to get the fuck out of here.
抽屉打开了，弄开了盒子，抓出了一大把——我的意思是——我的意思是，我要说是大概一英寸厚的杰斐逊钱。我要说是，像，一英寸，像个不错的——大概等同于MP铅笔盒里的钱。所以我把它分成了两半，然后塞进我的口袋里。我就想，我得快滚出这里。
Tone is running out of time. He does a sweep of the room, then he exits through the classroom door and locks it behind him.
托恩的时间不多了。他迅速查看了一遍房间，然后穿过教室门，在身后锁上了门。
I'm good. Like, I'm home free. So I close the door. I back out. Door is locked. And I'm starting to walk around the corner, and I've run into Natasha. Like, blew my mind. I'm also like, why is she in the hallway?
我没事。就像，我安全了。所以我关上门。我退了出来。门锁上了。我开始走到拐角处，就撞到了娜塔莎。就像，让我惊呆了。我还想，为什么她在走廊里？
And I mean, she looks at me. She knows that I'm not supposed to be here. But also she's looking at me like, why were you in Ms. Jefferson's class? And I mean, I swear to you, she just looks me up and down and just notices my pockets because, I mean, I got dollar bills-- I got Jefferson bucks, I mean, just popping out of my pockets. Oh, man.
我的意思是，她看着我。她知道我不应该在这里。但她看着我就像，为什么你在杰斐逊女士的班里？我的意思是，我向你发誓，她只是把我从上到下看了一遍，注意到了我的口袋，因为我的意思是，我有美元钞票——我有杰斐逊钱，我的意思是，正从我的口袋里爆出来。噢，该死。
And she just looks me up and down. And she was like, oh. [LAUGHS] She's goes, oh, I'm going to need some of that. And I'm like, oh my god. Like, this girl who I'm infatuated with, one, is robbing me. But like, to not get caught, I have to give this bitch hush money.
她只是把我从上到下看了一遍，然后说，噢。[笑] 她说，噢，我得要点那个。我就想，噢天哪。就像，这个让我迷恋的女孩，第一，正在抢劫我。但为了不被抓住，我得给这个贱人封口费。
So I think I gave her my whole left pocket, if I'm not mistaken, because it was already split in half. And right before I go back to lunch, I'm like, hey, just do not say nothing about-- are we good? And just like, hey, man. You know, we kind of had a cone of silence. Like, can we keep this shit a secret?
所以我认为我给了她整个左口袋的钱，如果我没记错的话，因为它已经被分成两半了。就在我回午餐之前，我就想，嘿，只是什么都别说——我们好吗？就像，嘿，伙计。你知道，我们达成了一种沉默契约。就像，我们能保守这个秘密吗？
Come back to Ms. Dillard's class. By the time we start the next period, I mean, everybody knows about it. I heard you took Jefferson bucks. I was like, mm-mm, I didn't take any Jefferson-- I was at lunch with you the whole time. I went to the bathroom. That's about it. So you start to see the eyeballs come at you like, oh, man, too many people know.
回到迪拉德女士的班里。到下节课开始时，我的意思是，每个人都知道了。我听说你拿了杰斐逊钱。我就想，嗯——嗯，我没拿任何杰斐逊——我一直和你在一起吃午餐。我去洗手间了。就这样而已。所以你开始看到眼球朝你投来，就像，噢，伙计，知道的人太多了。
Within no time, word spreads to Ms. Jefferson, and then the principal or vice principal. Tone can't remember which.
很快，消息就传到了杰斐逊女士那里，然后是校长或副校长。托恩不记得是哪位了。
And they pull me into the hallway. Ms. Dillard comes out. They're like, where were you during lunch? And I was like, I went to the bathroom. I asked for permission. And they're like, so you didn't go anywhere else? And I was like, no, I just went, and I came back. And they're like, OK, so what's in your pockets? And I was like, nothing.
他们把我拉到走廊里。迪拉德女士出来了。他们就像，你午餐时去哪儿了？我说，我去洗手间了。我征求了许可。他们就像，所以你没去过别的地方？我说，不，我只是去了，然后我就回来了。他们就像，OK，你口袋里有什么？我说，什么都没有。
It's still in your pocket?
它还在你的口袋里？
I didn't have time to put it up.
我没时间把它放起来。
Oh, you are the worst criminal.
噢，你真是最糟糕的罪犯。
[LAUGHS] I didn't have time to-- my plan was getting foiled in front of my eyes because I had too many eyeballs on me to take it out of my-- there's nothing I could do. I felt I was wearing a wire and people knew about it.
[笑] 我没时间——我的计划在我眼前破灭了，因为我有太多眼睛盯着我，没法把它从我的——我什么也做不了。我感觉我就像戴着窃听器，人们都知道了。
Even with the money as evidence, Tone still won't confess. So they turn up the heat. Into the hallway walks Natasha.
即使有钱作为证据，托恩还是不肯坦白。所以他们加大了压力。娜塔莎走进了走廊。
Yeah, she comes out. And she was like, well, I saw him coming out of Ms. Jefferson's room. And I was like, what? I mean, like, it was unreal.
是的，她出来了。她说，好吧，我看到他从杰斐逊女士的房间里出来。我说，什么？我的意思是，这太不真实了。
That's why I gave you the money, not to talk, especially to these people. That's why I gave it to you. Like, if you was going to tell the whole time, I would've just kept all of it. Like, if this was how it was going to end-- like, that's what the money was for. And I go to the office, and it's our-- it's either our principal, the vice principal, but it's definitely Ms. Jefferson.
这就是我给你钱的原因，不要说话，尤其是对这些人。这就是为什么我给了你。比如，如果你一直都要说，我本该全留着的。比如，如果这是结局——比如，那才是钱的用途。我去了办公室，是我们——或者是我们的校长，或者副校长，但绝对有杰斐逊女士。
Did she ask you anything?
她问了你什么吗？
She was definitely disappointed. She was definitely disappointed. And then, you know, she's-- why would you do that? And I was real. And I was like, look, man, it wasn't to be malicious. It was like, we struggling out here.
她绝对很失望。她绝对很失望。然后，你知道，她问——你为什么要那样做？我很诚实。我说，看，伙计，不是为了恶意。就像，我们在外面挣扎。
I'm sick of seeing people with three chocolate milks, and five Blow Pops and Ring Pops and all this kind of shit, and I can't do nothing. And it's like, well, there's a better way to go about it. I tried that. And you can't tell me that you don't remember. We kind of all talked about it.
我厌倦了看到人们有三杯巧克力奶，五根Blow Pop和Ring Pop，还有所有这些该死的东西，而我什么也做不了。就像，嗯，有更好的方法去做。我尝试过那个。你不能告诉我你不记得了。我们几乎都谈过那个。
And I've tried everything. I've tried what you said to do. I've tried to make better grades. I've tried to be more chivalrous. I've tried to not get my name on the board. I've tried all these things, and they don't work. I've tried to be fair, and you're not being fair.
我已经尝试了一切。我尝试过你说要做的。我尝试过取得更好的成绩。我尝试过更有骑士精神。我尝试过不让我的名字上黑板。我尝试了所有这些事情，但它们都没用。我尝试过公平，而你不公平。
Tone's punishment, the worst possible outcome. They call his dad. In Tone's mind, this is his last day on Earth. He gets home, goes straight to the fridge, gets a bowl of ice cream, and heads to his room to watch porn. He figures he might as well go out with a bang.
托恩的惩罚，最坏的结果。他们给他爸爸打了电话。在托恩心中，这是他在地球上的最后一天。他回到家，直接走到冰箱前，拿了一碗冰淇淋，回房间看色情片。他想既然要完蛋，不如轰轰烈烈一点。
He's refilling his bowl when he notices something. There's a chair in the middle of the kitchen. His dad walks in, gestures to the chair, and says--
他正要往碗里续冰淇淋时注意到了某事。厨房中间有一把椅子。他爸爸走进来，指着椅子说——
Oh, no, no, no, no. No. You know what time it is. And like, I'm like, ooh, fuck. You know, I've got to bend over the back of his chair, and I'm just taking it. I mean, I'm just breaking down.
噢，不，不，不，不。不。你知道现在是什么时候。我就像，噢，该死。你知道，我得弯腰趴在椅子背上，我只能承受着。我的意思是，我正在崩溃。
And then my father just like-- he stops. I'm crying and everything. And then he goes, hey, Tone. And I look back, and my father takes a Polaroid of me crying with the-- I mean, like it's-- pants are at my ankles, ass just-- I mean, face is like-- I mean, took a Polaroid.
然后我父亲只是——他停了下来。我在哭，什么都顾不上了。然后他说，嘿，托恩。我回头一看，我父亲拍了一张我正在哭的宝丽来照片，裤子在脚踝，屁股——我的意思是，脸就像——拍了一张宝丽来。
And what was the expression on your face?
你脸上的表情是什么样的？
The expression-- pain and defeat.
表情——痛苦和失败。
Tone never got another spanking. He never went rogue again. And part of that has to do with the Polaroid. Anytime he started acting up, his dad would remind him of that photo, and Tone would course correct.
托恩再也没挨过打。他再也没胡闹过。部分原因就是那张宝丽来。每当他开始行为不端，他爸爸就会提醒他那张照片，托恩就会纠正行为。
I mean, it was, like, Pavlovian. It was like-- I mean, that photo made me break down.
我的意思是，这就像，巴甫洛夫式的。我的意思是，那张照片让我崩溃。
Tone was ashamed. He felt bad for robbing the bank. But the thing is, it actually got him what he wanted. Not like he expected-- he didn't get Jefferson bucks. But he got justice. Ms. Jefferson changed the rules. No matter how many times a day you saw her, you could only earn money during the hour of math class. It became a level playing field.
托恩感到羞耻。他为抢劫银行感到难过。但问题是，它确实让他得到了他想要的。不是他期望的那样——他没得到杰斐逊钱。但他得到了正义。杰斐逊女士改变了规则。无论你一天见她多少次，你只能在数学课那一小时赚取钱。这成了一个公平的竞争环境。
I feel like I do remember people kind of being disappointed. There was people in Ms. Jefferson's class that were pissed, I'm sure. But everybody who wasn't in Ms. Jefferson's class was like, yo, about time.
我觉得我确实记得人们有点失望。杰斐逊女士班里的人很生气，我肯定。但每个不在杰斐逊女士班里的人都像，哟，早该这样了。
Mm-hm. Yeah. But you know what's interesting about what you're saying right now is just, like, the kids in Ms. Jefferson's class are going to be pissed at you because they don't have the privilege they used to have, right? But they also have no concept of how you've been feeling all school year.
嗯。是的。但你知道你现在说的话最有趣的地方在于，杰斐逊女士班里的孩子会因为失去了他们以前拥有的特权而生你的气，对吧？但他们也完全没有概念这一学年你是怎么过来的。
Exactly. You don't know it's different for me. Well, I'm in her class, and you get to take her class. Isn't that the same? No. I know it should be, but it's not. That doesn't matter to me. Well, then I have to do something. It felt unfair.
正是。你不知道这对我是不同的。好吧，我在她的班里，你也能上她的课。这不一样吗？不。我知道它应该是一样的，但它不是。这对我来说没关系。好吧，那我就得做点什么。这感觉不公平。
For Tone, this was always just a funny story he told about his dad's awkward Polaroid. But he started talking to me about it a few weeks ago, during the height of the recent protests. And that made him think about the story differently.
对托恩来说，这故事一直只是他讲述他爸爸那张尴尬的宝丽来的有趣故事。但他几周前开始和我谈论它，在最近抗议活动的高峰期间。那让他换了一个角度思考这个故事。
There's a parallel that I've never noticed or looked for, I guess, between how communities react when they don't feel like they're being treated fairly.
有一个我以前从未注意到或寻找过的平行点，我想，在社区感到待遇不公时的反应之间。
Well, you know, what it makes me think of is, like, Jesus always talked in parables.
嗯，你知道，这让我想起，比如，耶稣总是用寓言说话。
Right.
对。
And I feel like your Jefferson bucks story is such a perfect parable.
我觉得你的杰斐逊钱故事是一个如此完美的寓言。
I agree. When the rules are the same for everyone and some people thrive and some people don't, but everyone's following them, why is it not equal? Why is it not fair? And I don't even know if it can be answered most of the time. But the question has to be asked.
我同意。当规则对每个人都一样，有些人成功了，有些人没有，但每个人都在遵循规则，为什么它不平等？为什么它不公平？我甚至不知道大多数时候它是否能被回答。但这个问题必须被提出来。
If this is a parable, almost everything lines up-- the systematic inequality, the unfairness, how sometimes you have to break the rules in order for them to change. I see what I'm supposed to learn from everyone. But the one thing neither of us could figure out is, what are we supposed to learn from Natasha? Tone never told anyone she took half the money. A crush is a crush. So the real robber actually got away with it.
如果这是一个寓言，几乎一切都对应上了——系统的不平等、不公平，有时你必须打破规则才能让它们改变。我看到了我应该从每个人身上学到的东西。但我们两人都无法弄清楚的一件事是，我们应该从娜塔莎身上学到什么？托恩从未告诉任何人她拿走了一半的钱。暗恋就是暗恋。所以真正的抢劫者实际上逃脱了惩罚。
Elna Baker is one of the producers on our show. Tone Bell performed a version of this story on the Comedy Central program This Is Not Happening. His first hour-long special, "Can't Cancel This," is now available on Showtime and Amazon Prime.
埃尔纳·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。托恩·贝尔在喜剧中心节目《这还没发生》（This Is Not Happening）中表演了这个故事的另一个版本。他的第一个小时特别节目《无法取消这个》（Can't Cancel This），现在在Showtime和亚马逊Prime上提供。
Our program was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld and me. People who made the show today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editors are Diane Wu and Sarah Abdurrahman. Executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks to Gianlucca Iazzolino, Michael Kimani, Joseph Ndiritu, Wycliffe Alutalala, Eyder Peralta, Monique Thompson, Kyle Dacuyan, Nicole Wallace, Deepali Gupta, Patricia Spears Jones, Laurel Chor, and all of the Uber drivers who agreed to talk with Benjamen Walker and me.
我们的节目由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德和我制作。今天制作节目的人包括比姆·阿德武米、埃尔纳·贝克、伊曼纽尔·贝里、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格拉夫、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的总编辑是黛安·吴和萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。特别感谢吉安卢卡·亚佐利诺、迈克尔·基马尼、约瑟夫·恩迪里图、威克利夫·阿卢塔拉拉、埃德·佩拉尔塔、莫妮克·汤普森、凯尔·达库扬、妮可·华莱士、迪帕利·古普塔、帕特里夏·斯皮尔斯·琼斯、劳雷尔·乔以及所有同意与本杰明·沃克和我交谈的优步司机。
Please check out the episode that Benjamen did called "Going Karura" on his podcast Theory of Everything. You can find it at theoryofeverythingpodcast.com or wherever you get your podcasts. Original music at the end of Act One was composed for us by Nicholas Payton. Our website is thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
请查看本杰明在他播客《万物理论》中做的名为“去卡鲁拉”的剧集。你可以在theoryofeverythingpodcast.com或你获得播客的任何地方找到它。第一幕结尾的原创音乐由尼古拉斯·佩顿为我们创作。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, of course, to my boss, Ira Glass, a man who still goes trick or treating on Halloween-- except now when he gets his treat, he still toilet papers the family's house.
当然，感谢我的老板，艾拉·格拉斯，一个依然在万圣节去“不给糖就捣蛋”的人——除了现在当他拿到糖果时，他依然会用卫生纸把那家人的房子裹起来。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, we call that tricking off.
噢，是的。是的，我们称之为“耍花招”。
I'm Sean Cole. Join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔。下周加入我们，了解更多《美国生活》的故事。